[Music]
Diana thank you so much for being here
thank you for having me of course so to
start please tell me about what your
company parallel learning does so we
provide both software and services to
school districts around the country we
work specifically with their special
education department so in K through 12
districts you have general education and
then you have special education which is
about roughly 15% of students who
usually have a learning or thinking
difference Mental Health Challenge and
we basically staff School psychologists
speech therapists special ed teachers a
whole host of different professionals
who work directly with students to make
sure that you know even this most
complex students are set up for success
in the
district I want to hear about the why
tell me about your founding Story how
this came about well I'll start with I
have dyslexia and ADHD so I fall very
squarely into the population of students
that we now work with here at parallel
and was lucky enough to have access to a
lot of res sources growing up my mom in
particular was very on top of things
made sure that I really reaped the
benefits of early detection and early
intervention for my my challenges and
was diagnosed when I was 7even years old
which is a very unique story most kids
are years behind in core academic
subjects or struggling with with very
severe mental health challenges before
anyone really intervenes on their behalf
and so with that was extremely motivated
by my own experience to kind of recreate
my reality at scale for more students
and was also paired with you know the
start of the pandemic when so many
students you know schools were
struggling but general education online
nevertheless you know special ed
students were just simply not getting
served at all and was you know extremely
kind concerned to see dire circumstances
and and that was kind of ultimate
culmination for jumping into parallel
I've been really excited to partner with
you know some amazing clinicians in the
space operators Engineers to really
bring parallel to life talk to me about
how many students and Educators you
serve and how that's grown over time
yeah it's grown a lot very quickly so we
started actually working with school
districts just over a year ago so prior
to that we were actually serving
families who are actually not getting
served within the school district so
we're looking for additional services
and that business was fantastic and
growing you know also very rapidly the
districts came to us and said you know
we we actually desperately need your
services as well and so that gave rise
in Spring of 2022 of when we started
deciding to work with school districts
directly that it's actually now 100% of
our business it's been an absolute you
know joy to work with districts you know
across the country we're in 15 states at
this point I'm serving thousands of
students per month doing both
psychological assessments speech
assessments mental health assessments
and then also doing the kind of ongoing
services so things like speech therapy
special ed teaching and so on so really
becoming this kind of Full Stop partner
I should say for school
districts
tell me about your fundraising Journey
what's that been like for you and how
much have you raised so far it's been a
really exciting Journey it's amazing to
see how many institutional investors
ultimately support our mission and
really want to see parallel grow I'm a
solo founder so fundraising has been
something that has like fully fallen on
my plate and with that we've gotten a
lot of traction so we've now raised
about 30 million in total so from some
of you know really the top investors out
there tiger Global obvious Ventures
rethink impact fund just let a small
round we've been really lucky to work
with you know kind of investors of all
different backgrounds both from the more
impact Centric investors who have you
know more education more Healthcare
specific experience to the kind of big
growth funds and really see it from all
sides so it's an amazing opportunity to
have you know everyone around the table
and everyone's been you know highly
supportive of making parallel what it is
today
one last question for you what would you
like your legacy to be I think as you
know a Founder in this space like you
have to say it's got a mission element
right like obviously everyone that works
for parallel it's great that we're a
venture back company and we're growing
quickly like the business success is
part of it but I think more than
anything that actually means that we've
done really a lot of good in the world
and that we've really helped change the
trajectory for students
just like myself that like frankly if I
did not have access for the resources
that I did early on I would not be
sitting here today I would not have the
confidence for that I would not have
that basic skill set with that in mind I
think that's probably like the biggest
motivation is how do I really you know
hit the point where I feel like we've
helped as as many students as we
possibly
[Music]
can